and how was your weekend
mine was good I'm here to present the
award for best achievement in visual
effects
today's visual effects artists are
revolutionising our theater experience
taking us on wild flights of fancy
creating characters limited only by
their fertile imaginations however in
the wrong hands this newfound technology
can be dangerous I think we've all seen
the Fred Astaire posthumous vacuum
cleaner commercials uh sucking up the
lint balls getting in the corner areas
jumping out the back no one in this room
is safe just look what they did to Bob
Dole putting him in a Visa commercial if
he was alive he'd be outraged
one can only imagine what they'll do to
me when I'm gone who wants gum I do I go
what ball no cavities
I'm sorry I just wanted to warn you but
you know how very dangerous it can be
let's take a look at some of the
groundbreaking worked on this year in
Dragonheart the film's makers set out to
make the most lifelike and personable
dragon ever created for a movie they
began by studying the many films of
actor Sean Connery who provided the
voice of dracco
how many dragons do you know it took the
talents of nominees Scot Squires
Phil Tippett James Strauss and KITT West
two years time to create a dragon unlike
any other ever seen before in
Independence Day nominees Volker angle
Douglas Smith clay penny and Joseph
visco soul destroyed real cars
and realistic versions of famous
buildings to create the awesome
destruction of an alien invasion for
twister nominees Stefan Fangmeier John
Fraser Habib's a Kapur and Henry
labounta used jet engines on the set to
simulate the power of a tornado and
built computer-generated twisters dust
particle by dust particle to produce
realistic tornados that smash through
everything including box-office records
and the Oscar goes to Volker Engel
Douglas Smith clay penny and Joseph
disco soul for Independence Day
now this is movie magic really okay I
like to thank a great team I'd like to
thank Bob hurry
cherry Claudio and a first or magua Gert
and other great people worked on this
movie and especially a thing roland
emmerich the director of independency
who made all this possible and to roll
in and Dean let's kick the tires and
light the fires there were over 300
people involved with the just the visual
effects and I'll thank each of them
later tonight I promise I do have to
thank roland emmerich our director thank
God he had a great sense of humor he was
with us every day and at all hours I'd
like to also thank Dean Devlin and Terry
Claudio and my wife Anna Chi thank you
thank Sam and Joey